hey what's up my name is Samuel leaves
welcome to win it on a Wednesday where
every single week on a Wednesday I bring
in one of my success students that have
become financially free by investing in
property this week I'm gonna be talking
to a girl called Stuart
Bao and he's gonna be explaining how he
became financially free from one
property deal you know takes just as
much energy to do one deal a big deal
and he's just to do a small deal so in
this video you learn exactly what he did
and how he did it so stay tuned I'm in
the wrong we very first met we talked at
a crash course in witness remember yes a
little bit of that into that top room
upstairs yes that's right and you were
telling me you're making really good
money as a surveyor and you're like
there's so much opportunity for me to be
able to see this sort of stuff myself
and I'm facilitating people's big deals
and I'm facilitating other people to
make those with money and whilst on paid
well I'm in a job and and and that was
about what 18 months ago that was I'm
gonna be successful yeah of what you do
now your full time property oh not at
the moment no so it's I'm bill I'm
building up I don't want to do the let's
jump and then a finalist I've got
another job yeah this time is in
property rather than in construction so
how much you making improper to yourself
now
at the moment it's about two and a half
thousand pounds which is not bad which
is not bad with dealers go through the
moment that should drag it up to about
four thousand but though that property
in Liverpool which is making it two and
a half thousand pounds that will be more
in the future it's a question of so you
actually just landed one deal which is
making you two and a half grand which is
why I want to talk about that particular
deal and also as well I think that
you'll probably be able the reasons I
wanted you on the show is because you'll
be a big inspiration to people that
might be in construction or people that
are in property whether they're
surveyors or even estate agents lawyers
and they're working in the property
industry and they're thinking man I want
to do a bit of this myself
how do you how do you manage to find the
time to be a full time professional in
property but also have your own thing
going on which which book which I don't
know about absolutely I do first
oh you've got to change your mindset
yeah it's got to be a change of mind so
you got to stop thinking or I'm going to
work and then I'll go off and play
football on a Saturday or something you
just got to change your mindset for
starts yeah you've got to go right okay
I need to get into property how am I
going to do listen first of all you
gonna you got to get your knowledge up
so you have to do things like the crash
course become a member of the Academy
find time to listen to the podcasts and
the and YouTube channel and just create
that time because most people got lots
of dead time they're just not there's
not using it properly oh yeah first of
all you've got to get that you've got to
get that that created and then you've
got to make sure that you you you use
that you use that time and then
information correctly so I'm probably
doing somewhere between 15 and 20 hours
a week as well as 17 and 20 on property
yeah they're 15 to 20 on property yeah
as well as having a full-time job at the
moment that's hardcore it's hot how many
I was working on your job anywhere
between probably up to up to 50 depends
what's going on so many people in that
situation would would would say I'm
working up to 50 hours a week I haven't
got time to do any property but you are
you know a living example that you can
make money and you're making pretty
decent money job are you enjoying it
right I enjoy it yes I do enjoy so you
didn't come to me a year and a half ago
and say I want to get out my job as soon
as I can what you said is I want to
build up wealth which will mean that in
time and a realistic amount of time I'll
be in the situation where I work because
I choose do not because I have to yeah
and you wanted to but what was your
strongest reason for getting into
property for that reason really it is
you look at it and you go well if
there's something happened I lost my job
tomorrow what do I live on and
ultimately you go on my wage was my
income and
got nothing else does provide an income
really yeah so it's the passive income
that I was looking for and so the you
know even now we've been coming up to a
year and that passive income that you
know there's building up in the
background you it's great because you
suddenly go oh I can't do anything this
month because I've ran out of cash flow
but actually that cash flows created
itself yeah and you can tap into that if
necessary so it's one of these things
that you it's giving you options and
which which you never not necessarily
have before so that's import me through
Stewart the deal man that was your big
first deal I know and it took you a
while to find it and you looked at a few
other things we even talked about doing
limited potentially I know in the early
days there was a different few but then
you found your deal and you went in what
were the figures the figures first well
first I think it's a good idea to talk
about the what I was trying to - yeah
and I was looking at everybody was doing
the three four beds hundred thousand
pounds tied UMass HMOs and chef like
that and I was thinking geez there's not
gonna be many of those left the way it's
going yeah so so I thought I think
slightly differently and with the
techniques that we talked on the Academy
you know you're sort of learning lots of
different things and you have to
sometimes you have to put a variety of
things together to get the right deal
and now the deal that I actually found
in the end was something that I would
not even consider previously you know
and was if it hadn't have been for the
Academy so it was a it's actually four
properties in one it's not one property
as before so it's three flats single
that flats at one bed into two beds and
there is a nine bed HMO big deal big
deal so when you say you got one
property really that's you actually
Connelly got four properties and one of
them being how many bedroom had to have
nine bed call on sweeted my goodness yes
sir cause it's only making two and a
half grand it will make more I will get
it it's it's it's it's an ongoing one
you make more money in the future and
I'll explain that so it was Sosa for
properties in Warren on the market for
five five eighteen that's a lot of money
the my all in money in the end was about
170,000 pounds for absolutely everything
yeah so that works out to be about
sixteen percent on the two and a half
that we're talking about but there's a
really nice up 16% I know you people go
well it's probably twenty isn't it so
but it's a reason why I bought that ones
because it's got a it's restarting it
just been done out brand-spanking-new
nine bed HMO fully let turnkey
everything else goes letter as well so
good starting yeah sure nice and simple
nice and easy for an engine I'd say easy
one busy for an entry-level it is quite
good so I really like that because it
was earning cash on day one cash flow
one day one yeah no no no risk so
looking at that and then there was also
because of the flats the way their their
elect I was considering maybe service
accommodation which in the end I've
chosen not to I think he was gonna be a
bit bit more hassle than it was probably
worth internally income it was going to
get back and but then oh but also
noticed that all the rents were too low
there should have been fifteen percent
higher so automatically as people move
on or be increase in the rents so be
going up by about 15% also because I'm a
first-time landlord and it's an unusual
property I got nailed on the mortgage so
it's so after I've generated it or time
and the mortgage companies get used to
me and see me more or there's not an
office anymore I should get it she'll
get it a better deal
how much is what you're talking of how
much money have to leave they know you
talk about the interest payments the the
interest payments I'm paying a five
point okay quite high now it's quite
heavy yes and I should be able to get
that a lot lower in the future also
it's for properties I'm considering a
title split' as well yeah because the
actual of the whole building itself is
on the ballot so so and because they're
for smaller more manageable you get more
people in the marketing to me so yeah I
see it being a in two years time when
I've done all of that it should be three
thousand two hundred pounds profit a
month from that I know I know that you
didn't want to come on windows Wednesday
too soon because you wanted to because
because women Wednesday mark typically
if someone's making a couple grand a
month that's kind of eligible to come on
the show and do what was done but you
were saying look I just want to see the
money coming in for it for a good few
months justice check it's legit you know
so how many months have you been
receiving your two-and-a-half grand
cert seven months now and he's putting
me pretty much smack on what I expected
it to be yeah I was really pleased I
think when I first started looking and
started talking to you about it every
time I looked at the numbers the
expenses went up or something went up
and it's like you suddenly had a foot
where you thought was a brilliant
brilliant scheme is that suddenly not
quite so good it's a lot of people get
caught up with that especially the
expenses and they get oh I didn't
realize that that's an average but
forget that they're gonna have to pay
the bills or they forget they're gonna
count to attack for something city
things like oh you got oh you're gonna
get an HMO license or something like
that they don't know they in fact in
that or insurance for the building I
mean it sounds really ridiculous like
some people forget those sorts of yeah
so you go well you know but on you buddy
a lot pizzas actually have been a big
number
but yeah but mine's actually hitting
what I thought it was going to hit at
the moment so I'm really yeah because
you have good training you're a
conservative person anyway your
backgrounds in property so you know you
know what you do it so let me ask you a
question then I mean you've you've
invested strategically and you're in a
situation where now you make in so
what's the what's the rent roll on that
then how much rent in again Oh crikey
that's about it's about five and a half
thousand pounds of five and a half
dollars that sounds about right so you
making a two and a half thousand pounds
profit each month it's going to go up
you're going to what you're going to
put the red tip you just gonna just push
them up a little boy who's McLaren no I
go well as people are moving out we
probably turn over from you the kid 12
18 months for everybody to turn over I
expect we've probably had about third
moved on already in the seven months
because we bought it from another guy
that just burn it up and he had 12
months worth of leases yeah everybody
was on that first 12 months so we first
started seeing people leave about 13 14
15 months yeah so a couple of months in
two hours which doesn't bother me
because I knew there the rents were too
low so uh someone moves in art moves out
on yeah put up the rent
so yeah I'm quite happy with that I've
got some really good tenants as well
I've got one guy that's cleaning how
petty lives cleaning so I think of my
point he's written down governing up
everybody for that what I wanted to ask
though is how nerve-wracking was it put
in or you know your lifelong savings
which you've sweated over and you to
just put that pump interest into
something and that money to be locked
away you know I mean how how scary was
that let's start very scary I'd say you
know yeah I think it's like anything
when you do it for the first time it's
unusual you you think what am I doing
here have a got it right have I made a
mistakes and hence why I talk to you
quite a lot in on that one I said just
do what this is it this is this this is
more time I saw you at one of the
training programs you'd come up to me
you'd be like so this bit yeah yeah you
took a while for it to go everything he
talked about really taking about eight
months to get it over the line in the
end from the moment we talked to talked
about it to the painfully long it was
painful and then that was mainly down to
solicitors but you know you want to
Stangl them off it's when you buying for
properties in one and it's such a big
deal yeah you know some things can't
they can't drag on so it was scary then
putting it it was scary but within two
months of having seen the money coming
in seeing it works okay made sure it yes
like this is easy
do you have any regrets regrets on that
property I probably didn't push the
number down low enough
mhmmm because I did have the opportunity
but I think that's because she you're
learning you're still learning a little
bit as you're going on but it's a good
price I know it's a good price I don't
think I didn't push it too hard because
I think they weren't gonna sell anything
they were considering refinancing and I
like the property it worked and I knew
it's turnkey I guess why do you think
they sold it if they've got a property
that's generating that kind of profit
what why did they even want to sell it
there they have another property that
they just bought and they needed the
money from that so they were motivated
to sell no it was it was it was good for
me and I actually kept in touch with
indigo because the property could have
gone back quite early on because of the
way the the solicitors were yeah but we
kept in very good communication pretty
much every other day me and the seller
and myself just talking about that so
that's really important otherwise that
product that would have gone but I keep
in touch with him he's got another
project they've even been around that
next project so it's it's and he's done
a really good really good job on that
we've even discussed in ago and talked
about what I think the rents would be
and what he could do so I've been
imparting some of my knowledge to him as
well so just to help him help him out on
his next one and maybe that was why I
wanted to say it to you yeah because you
you got on and you helped him and gave
knowledge what do you think once you've
title split' yet yeah what's your
estimation of the end value I think it
could we could be taking out another
50,000 pounds out of that yeah it's so
not only will I be up to 20 21 % be able
to take another 50 grand out always say
when you're by probably I guess is this
three ways well there's only really
three ways you can get paid from
property one is when you buy something
at a good price below market value
you've immediately made some equity yeah
second way is cash flow your properties
I mean you've got a pretty good price
you're making good cash flow and then
the third way is capital appreciation as
the property goes up talk to me a bit
about that and how you how you decided
to choose that area I suppose I didn't
really I chose I chose Liverpool
because I found it easier to find the
HMO properties when you're looking
online a right move yeah I think in
Liverpool's quite as easy as you think
and it's quite difficult in where the
main areas are but this area wasn't in
the city center wasn't in the student
there was it was quite quite a way out
of town but it the way I looked it was
it was well it's it's it's fully let and
there was demand in the area so if
there's if it's fully letting this
demand then why wouldn't I consider
buying it so he didn't quite tick the
boxes that you would normally do but it
was it was close to a big state area so
there's lots of jobs down that way
though so so it worked for that sort
thing so I didn't choose I didn't choose
the area the area chose me from finding
it on yeah I guess if it's fully left I
mean the only thing you need to be
careful of is if a landlord fills a
property just to sell it but actually
there's such a high turnaround it's too
bad demographic of tenants how do you do
your due diligence you're a man of a lot
of due diligence no I think if you'd
have bought property for 70 grand mhm
and it was a three or four bit HMO it
might be a different story but when you
put in everything into one massive
project that's effectively going to make
you financially free because I mean make
maybe you're over into more than two and
a half grand but a lot of people could
live the capital you start with as well
yeah but you put your money into one
deal
yeah which has given you an income which
effectively for a lot of people is
financial freedom and so if you got
fired tomorrow oh really it would be I
wouldn't be panicking in quite the same
way or will it be times again yes so
he's one of those things you good
because you've got an income that's
coming from somewhere else that that
pressure to have a job dissipate a bit
or if you get over the depression you go
do you know what I can have a month off
whilst I find the right job or or go
into property full-time or or do
something do so it's it's one of those
things that you it gives you the options
and I
you've got to have options if you don't
have options then you generally have
some poor results though so how do you
do that we make it a big investment
decision how do you do dude no jokes on
that on that one I was first of all I
got all the details of the listen
landlord I had a good chat with him
spoke to the management company spoke to
other management company went to spare
rooms checked all those out do due
diligence on all those different things
in it and you look at it and you go well
he's actually his numbers are too low
and the HMO itself absolutely superb I
live there yeah I can he live there the
flats that came with it looked at them I
would live there it was done really
nicely I could see that they are met the
the seller several times passionate
about
he's the people that were living there
and providing a good service you could
just see it in everything he did do you
think that would you advise somebody
because I often say that a big deal
takes just as much time to buy as a
small deal you make a lot more money on
a big deal hmm but however often you'll
make mistakes on your first deal so so
that is his argument of do you start
small and work your way up big or do you
just go straight in big I mean what
advice would you give to somebody oh
jeez that's a tough one it's all about
your due diligence yeah the end of the
day you as I said earlier you go oh I
didn't realize about that I didn't
realize that and personally I kicked
myself if I didn't if I didn't know all
the information on day one I'd be quite
annoyed with myself if I if I if I
missed a big cost because through
ignorance you know that's to me that's
does is to to get that wrong so I think
if you're new to I think because of my
background in construction you doing our
due diligence anyway so I was quite
happy doing that all our due diligence
because I bought properties myself when
the house that I live in
you get to understand that and going
through the Academy you talk to other
people and everybody shares information
it makes a big difference on your
confidence or whether something's going
to work on yes so it's so for me if if
your total a total total of this then I
would suggest probably go in tip-tippy
toe in and do a smaller one and then go
to something a little bit bigger and I I
didn't aim to go for a big one it just
the way it came along he just we just
happened and as I did everything spoke
to yourself spoke to other people for
well he worked why wouldn't I do it if I
know it works why wouldn't it work so
yeah that's ultimately where you need to
so I guess if you are going to go big
straightaway I guess the key is to just
make sure you've got good people around
you you good support you're able to ask
people more experience than you hey can
you have a look over at the deal if you
can have someone that can look over the
deal and go it's done it all before and
go yeah you've got this right or no
there's something not quite right there
all this you've missed something here or
don't forget about this we don't you
know don't forget about this item I mean
that might affect your profitability in
the future yeah if you've got that sort
of knowledge and you've got then you've
got a tap into it if you haven't got
that knowledge then you made to go into
something quite so big early on you
might just want to step back from that
and just have a good think about it you
can get hold of someone mmm please do
get hold of someone for sure it's a big
dish
and I know you've also on the academy
it's not just about having mentors or
people that are you know trainers it's
also just having people that might be
three or six months or a year ahead of
you also that may be just finishing the
Academy you can see that I have to
repeat in the Academy three about fully
out of six months and you come along and
you knew you were coming you can tell by
the questions that were asked that
they're in you and you can almost go
you're three months you're six months
you've done a year you know and that's
because you know the questions changed
the questions
stopped being basic questions they're
more
more detailed and more specific about
something that you're actually looking
at yeah yes I read it it does make a
difference and being able to talk to
someone that's I know I've already done
that you potentially don't want to go
down that route from this ruse yeah and
the least then even if you do go down
that route you are you've got that
knowledge from someone else and you go
oh yeah but think about that before I go
down there so it does make a difference
what deals have you got going on at the
moment then at the moment I have a well
I've started sourcing to because to me
it's an actual progression when you're
looking for properties yeah there you've
seen lots of lots of properties that you
can and can't do I can't get involved in
that one at the moment because there's
too much going on everyone should be a
professor yeah oh we're bow down yeah
we've got to me complete logic is to
become a sorcerer yeah you know you
might not be doing what Alice Terra's
doing yeah we have bed sauce and
knocking them out by a dozen yes at the
same time if you've doing one maybe two
or you've just got your just sourcing
for one or two people yeah then you've
got that intimacy with someone and so
what are you looking for so when you
start looking at these things you go I'm
specifically going out for this type of
property in this area or this type of
area then you can you use something got
a focus yeah which makes you you've got
you've got more even more options again
more choices also looking for when
you're sourcing I guess there's two
types of property sources there's one
which says you know I am a property
sorcerer and they'll go out and they'll
be hunting for deals all the time for
people and then the other kind of
sorcerer is someone that just does it
alongside their own property investing
so and if you're it's like when you went
for a bus suddenly two would come at
once you can't buy both instead of
letting one go down the drain pass it on
to somebody else
charge a finder's fee and that's great
what about next year what's your what
eat what are your plans moving forward
of your property Danny you got to a
stage where I know you invested a ton of
money into this one deal which is great
because it's effectively made you
financially free by some people's terms
how are you going to continue building
your portfolio now because I've been
sorting looking at that
I really expected the the cash flow that
I personally yeah I'm looking at over
streams at that point so I'm I'm looking
at the the sourcing that makes a big
difference
yeah but also I've got a lot of people
looking at me interesting seeing what
I'm doing cause I you know I haven't hid
from people saying I'm not telling them
what I'm doing this is what I'm doing
okay that's interesting they keep asking
me about it that's for friends and
friends and family on that yeah and
they're watching from a distance and it
every now and they're gonna go well
how's that HAP see Liverpool go exactly
what it's supposed to do yeah so I've
even thrown a few people around it so
you know just just just to say this is
what we're doing we're gonna okay got
that
so I found they when I was sorting I
found an absolutely terrific property
similar sort of idea with someone had
developed it and wanted to sell it on
because they have another project you
know purpose-built HMO absolutely
stunning
inside and I think that the cash flow is
one of those things that I've loved to
buy it and said do you know what I'll
give you the money for that so to get on
it and they said I don't want to be the
landlord do they want to do any of that
I just want to return on invest they
gave you the money for it that's right
oh you get so I haven't is still is
still ongoing at the moment but that
one's going through and that's going to
be a terrific one that's going to be the
property or is that what you'll get
that's the property yeah but that's
based on that's a 6 bed HMO but it's
actually got a seventh bed and it's and
it could actually be 8 because of the
the licensing laws you could do that so
how are you let's just be conservative
and yeah 1100 yeah I know you love fact
I did all the other costs because I know
what you're like so let's say it's 1100
only if he puts the money in how are you
going to structure the joint venture I
pay a return
then after five years we we look to
remortgage that that property okay I
give them the money back so that's
pretty much easy just it's just cash so
a week so that won't be a joint-venture
percent be more like raise finance base
finance so basically you'll give him
what kind of return you give it
I didn't Empson okay I've got you know
it's a good property yeah I they got
money sit in the bank to show that
eleven hundred pounds is that after
you've paid them their 10 percent or
before yeah that's before they say
although they'll be taking 400 pounds
right it's actually it's a six will be a
city definitely will be a seven yeah
potentially be an eight so we're talking
another and once you start factoring all
those cash it's actually making just as
much as well one extra room can
sometimes double your profit can't this
so okay so you're gonna borrow you're
gonna borrow the money pay ten percent
yeah and then you're gonna rent the
house out they'll get seven hundred
you'll get four hundred plus extra rooms
if you can and then it's your property
that's right and then five years later
you receive a valid value or whatever
you refinance it and paid the person
back which seems I mean what why why
don't you think more people do that for
those people for your for your friends
if he's got the money in the bank he
doesn't know about how to invest in
property instead of getting 0.5 percent
he's exactly twenty times as much you
turn on any wood from the bank I mean
why do you think more people don't just
do that I think it's it's confidence in
the person you're investing in isn't it
no I haven't rushed into any of this you
know it's taken me 18 months to get to
this position and you know I didn't go
do the crash course and then run out and
buy an HMO tomorrow yeah it wasn't us
people that know me know I take my time
I know I don't rush into things I only
go in to do the deal if I know it works
and nobody's gonna know it's going 207
work so people know me that who do that
and said well fair enough you know I
believe in you here you're giving me a
great return on invest
and and I know the property I've shown
the property I've given them figures
over and they've gone yeah I can see
this working I don't know I think in
property you can't cut corners but what
you can do is you can fast-track
portfolio growth so what you're probably
fine you start doing this is you'll be
thinking I worked I mean how many years
is it take you to save up that memo that
well as follows it's a lifetime isn't it
ultimately so it see if you said from my
working life probably 15 years right so
you spent 15 years you know saving up
money to then put into a property which
has worked and that's good but for you
to then continue to grow if you had some
if you had to work 15 years every time
you wanted to buy a property that's
that's really slow so you can fast track
it yeah by doing things like joint
ventures yeah raising finance but now
you've got the case study of this one
you know the confidence they would trust
or respect to be able to to be able to
do that and what what I want to do with
this with this neck with this next
project yes that is to actually document
it and show people because I like I like
numbers and I stats I like you know I've
taken my time because I like to know
it's correct so it's a lot of people get
struggle with the with the numbers have
a gonna try and they get paralyzed and
don't do the deal because again our list
by that's right that's right
that's that would be your danger though
yeah it could be big big I understand it
now so I'm happy to move quicker now
yeah I probably was at the beginning but
since I got the numbers I understood the
numbers I don't know it works I've moved
on to this next this next deal I saw the
property went home quickly looked at it
oh god that works what offer
how have you changed over the last eight
six it's been on the Academy and
becoming a professional prominent
investor how do you think you've changed
as a person or grown I think knowledge
wise is this a different set of
knowledge a different way of looking at
things
you definitely look at things
differently you should always looking
well hang on that's a nice property but
it doesn't quite work why isn't it work
how am I going to make it work you know
and you're looking like look at that
you're always looking you're always
looking up you're always looking at what
where where can we
where can we do the deal and better
relationships talking to people a lot
more finding out a lot more about what
they do
[Music]
I'm here as a to do this and you just
focused on your own little thing and I
find that you you when you start talking
to people not necessarily about property
just how things come out and then
suddenly going on that's a lead that I
didn't even consider previously
yeah.well this person I've known for ten
years I didn't even know they had a
property or something like this so it's
a it's a big it's getting to know people
in different ways
do you feel a little bit like you know
when you get a new car you still see
that car everywhere yeah when you learn
about how to be a property investor when
you get the skills some of the you just
see opportunities everywhere oh you do I
walk around and go oh that looks a nice
property yeah all that one's rundown
I'll get on and do where you think why
am I gonna find out who owns it and you
go oh ting things down as you walk
around yeah see you we're in your head
or on a notepad and you go going back in
the weekend and you go well I quickly
have a look at that and and find out a
bit more about that oh what's that
what's the sales value in this area this
is a nice area how why is this one on to
cheat was this one on so cheaply and
that one's not yeah it's a you you are
constantly thinking I date I think once
you start getting into property you
don't switch off from it yeah so you
you've constantly seen the D or you're
constantly thinking about the deal and I
think that's the it's the mindset change
I think really yeah I've got I've got a
job but I've also got my property as
well as well and you you saw a look at
that sort of stuff and you go well I
think we can I can I can do something
different and also spotting people to
joint venture with yeah what people that
can people that were maybe worried
family or friends colleagues you never
even thought anything before but now
you've got the skills to raise
financially we could do something
together talk to me about the about yuge
builds on the crash course the crash
course especially about going back in
the day I actually found yourself from
your book yeah who's that is that
there's that difficult bit between
Christmas and New Year and people that
you sort go what do I do
well I need to get to do something look
at property and I and I just all of the
top three books on Amazon and they all
came through and yours was the second
one the first one I went okay second one
read yours thinking to me about two and
a half hours to read from start to
finish and I immediately knew it worked
that was by low rent hi that's right I
knew it worked the moment I read it I
went didn't you meet someone you go well
yeah that works that works yeah you got
I can't believe I don't know this why
don't I know this and that from that
first night you sort of I couldn't sleep
I just couldn't sleep
sorry about that yeah you saw they sort
of wake up and you go you're doing that
so that was that was the first night
then that I saw in the backyard book you
had a Facebook page went on a Facebook
page and in your advertising the crash
course and came onto the crash course
had two great days really enjoyed it I
get bored in seminars but I didn't yawn
once in two days
which is pretty good for you to to do
that and the energy and the knowledge
that you you you departed on that on
that day it was amazing two days and to
be free as well off the back of that I
thought well I've got the Academy why
not why wouldn't I I've just had two
days there it's just given me so much
information and I want to learn more
yeah and how did you find it have you
found the Academy finished yeah but
what's on that coming member yeah we
always stay in touch that's right it's I
think every time I went to the
most there were like two three day cause
I think you might change since that's a
suicide so every time you go there you
learn something new and you go oh really
and you go you'd run off and you go off
in the next couple of weeks you start go
I'm going to do this me do that and then
you're coming on to the next one it
would be like really I'll scrap that one
I'm going on to this so you you you
you're constantly improving your
knowledge and yeah by the time you get
you stop you you stop being mind blown
and after about the fourth the fourth
one after the fourth set of three days
or something like that and you go okay
this is the knowledge is just it's just
immense really and there you can live
off the crash course if you really want
to but I I think the Academy is
something that's just ads ads and ads
and ads - yeah well are you you've been
a great student because I think the
thing is we can give we can give
knowledge but knowledge without
implementation is nothing but the fact
that you've implemented you've got that
cracking property you've got more deals
in the pipeline
I guess what can we expect if we did a
winners Wednesday part two with you in
12 months what can we expect to say all
right so I've seen the next one I'll be
doing is bye-bye we further finance I'm
probably going to do something like a
conversion to an HMO yeah that way so I
can get greater returns yeah that's what
I'd like to do a few more of those and
ultimately my backgrounds in
construction so you know it's it's gonna
be a it's gotta be investment at some
point yeah I build stuff I live in
Bristol we live in Bristol how do you
find investing in Liverpool when you're
living in Bristol hard work yeah gone
you know streets spin off hours there
you know yes back but you just got to
make the time ultimately you can do you
can do your your homework during the
week and then you go okay on this for
the next couple of Saturdays or Sundays
or during the week or whenever you do it
I'm gonna be up in Liverpool
yeah or I work in the Merseyside area so
I'm looking in that area do you think it
forces you far away cuz I now live in
London my property is all up north for
me I kind of find it forces you to set
up good systems cuz if you lived in
Liverpool guaranteed to be there every
week where is because you don't you
might be going down there in the early
days but it forces you to put together a
good power team good system so you don't
need to travel there what do you think
of that yeah it takes it takes a while
to to get that right set of people to
figure out about that and do that and
especially with the with the sourcing
you've got to think about who can I
trust to view a property and not and not
making mistakes yeah so that sort of
stuff we I'm still developing and it's
taking a while I'm still getting to know
my areas once I've got to know those
areas I'll probably be doing less and
less going would you advise people that
are living maybe down south Bristol or
London or wherever would you advise them
to try and invest where they live or
would you say it's better than the Duke
farm where the deal's off
it's tricky as you see so you've got the
cash or not ultimately if you're further
south you need more money
the deals are not quite the same further
south you don't get the super below
market value items that you in the
southeast personally I've gone up north
I'm quite happy with that that process
yeah travelling up and back again is
hard work yeah but hey ho that's that's
life until I've got the system set up
and I've got someone else that I can
send up there and to look at it yeah and
I trust just one of those things I would
personally carry on going up north until
if I was full-time in property I might
look elsewhere and start looking at
different things know someone or employ
someone that's right
yeah that's the next we'll work with you
on that yeah yeah what you've got a
family
yeah got my wife yes yes Zimbabwean
that's right that's right so respected
Zimbabwe
how she cope with all this whirlwind of
it when I went to the crash course shoot
you know she fell okay fair enough
when I came back from the crash course
and said I've signed up to the Academy
she went really and she was like what
she just said well you've never done
anything like that ever because I'm
quite careful with money yeah whether
it's my mind my money or other people's
money so it's it's it was quite a shock
to her and we did the Academy and she
could see that I was getting quite
getting involved and then we are said
right okay we're gonna buy something now
um we went and she rose I want to come
with you because I don't want you just
going off and buying a property without
without you know it's a joy yeah he's
bought this bought it we went up and we
had on a big day in their pool and we
saw about seven or eight properties
first one was an absolute shocker
Laura was not the right one to be
showing her first then we saw a couple
of others and the last one we saw is the
one we actually bought walked around it
had a look at it and and her first thing
was like God live it so he's running one
of these things walked out there I did
the due diligence checks out all the
numbers I said look we can buy this one
issue Inchon yeah fine looking back is
she very glad that you did the Academy
went falling into poverty is she happy
now I think I would have thought so yes
it should be yeah there's more income so
it's more options that's all to me I'm
so I can say really all these things you
can do things that you want to do that
you didn't you can be a leader to be a
leader you've got to take some risks
you know property investing there's
always gonna be an element of risk same
as joining the enemy or even giving up
two days to go to the crash course
there's a risk you know waste time yeah
but in order to be a true leader and
lead your family yeah you gotta take
risks you have to and also a lot of my I
said my friends are looking on in
interest yeah
and they're actually going well Jesus
I'm gonna have to chase you now because
they see what I'm doing and going well I
I know it works so I'm gonna have to
have a look at that and you know get
involved because it's ultimately what
it's about you you can get yourself
financially free you can and you can try
and help other people yeah I'm fine I
should be like you have done through the
and there's a joy in helping other
people it is yeah I know it's it's that
knowledge and it's it's not as if you do
you're doing something that helps
everybody so you're doing really good
quality rental property you're getting
good income from yeah that's you can you
can depart your knowledge you can get a
decent income from it you can do other
things as off the back of it if you help
enough people get what they want you'll
get what you want right same is that you
know me helping you and do you use an ID
your own property and then we ended up I
know if it came but it could do we could
maybe do adventure we don't think you
know you just build relationships good
relationships always better than a good
deal correct so final question then and
it's been great it's been great catching
up and chatting with you but final
question before introduce you to the
team down at the office what would be
the biggest piece of advice you'd give
somebody watching this who's in the job
and they're wanted to get into property
like you were a couple years ago you
just got to find the time and you're
going to be committed that's all - Mele
what you've got to do you know I made a
decision soon as I'm a decision on going
on the Academy on getting to property I
just rate at the time you know just got
to create at the time we're seeing
people say I'm gonna view 500 houses in
the next month
I mean silly like that and I go well
that's not sustainable you can't do that
for it so you got you set yourself
something you'll stretch you but at the
same time will not choose all your all
your spare time you can't you know
you've gotta have some time for your
family or or for other items so I'd say
you've got to create the time you've got
to be diligent at it you've got to keep
going
and you you just got to be committed
[Music]